how do you balance being a player
as well as a mother i just
you just do it you just get it done you
find a way what's today maya
what what is it
you look so cute
motherhood is a 24 7 job when the wnba
announced plans for a bubble of their
own
derricka hamby of the las vegas aces and
several other wnba players
had a difficult decision to make opt out
of the upcoming season altogether or
opt in and bring their children into
what's been aptly named
the wubble i didn't think we were going
to have a season this year i was
debating on if i was going to opt in or
opt out
but once i knew that i was going to opt
in i knew maya would come with me
i wasn't sure if i was going to bring
her or not because i wasn't sure how
safe it would be but
actually going there and being there it
was as safe as it could be for her
once inside the wubble at img academy in
bradenton florida figuring out that
work-life balance was
no easy task parenting in the bubble was
an adjustment
it's a tough season we're doing pretty
well it's nothing that we wanted to do
it's just something that we have to do
right now
she's got a lot on her plate and doing
every aspect of it at a very high level
some of the kids are able to be there to
experience
what this wubble shortened season is
like
like how do you keep them entertained
[Laughter]
when you're in isolation where your two
main jobs coincide
finding time for yourself can be the
most challenging part
i will say it is difficult when i'm
taking a pregame nap and she's in pe
and they're hoolooping and jumping rope
and when she's in music class and
they're doing music
it can get a little difficult as an
adjustment you're getting treatment
you're
you're coming over to get tested all the
time shoot around practice game
shoot around practice game and then some
days i just want to sleep
it is exhausting to take care of a
three-year-old in life
and derek is balancing that she's
balancing playing at a very high level
and her daughter amaya is adorable and
precious and yet it does take a ton of
energy
i mean you only practice two hours out
of the day but it just seems like you
still have no time
but just kind of being able to find a
balance of
keeping yourself sane and also being
able to contribute to your team success
also being able to come back and be a
mom helps
without daycare services players had to
look to other means of child care
their teammates friends and family were
ready to step in
my teammates they love her that alone
speaks for herself
candace was a big help we're neighbors
or layla spent a lot of time in the maya
amaya are we friends yeah okay so like
real friends
get in the ice bath together i i can't
stay in front of you
and blast the kids yes let's do it come
on
they just bring so much joy to everybody
in the bubble and really take the edge
off of everyone
we got our lucky charm right here just
having her hair i feel like that's my
stress relief but i'm not having a good
day or
being able just to see her grow every
day and be here with me we're in this
bubble
while i'm still doing my job um it
definitely means a lot and you know i'm
glad i decided to bring her
are you dancing i think i will remember
the experience
i think i've learned that it truly does
take a village it takes a lot of people
and i think this bubble has shown up to
be in a historic season in the wubble
i think we're making the best of it